[Applause]
[Music]
being one day
these people are crazy
wow I hope you had a good weekend I
spent mine like I always do shooting
rats with my BB gun and Cat's office
but that ranks pretty low on the most
interesting thing to happen over the
past few days and I think you know what
I'm talking about
he's back all right
true it's true Elon Musk has reinstated
Donald Trump's Twitter account he was
unsuspended like my pants when I used to
dance at Chippendales
that's after musk posted a poll in which
over 15 million users voted in favor of
reinstatement
of course we're still waiting on the
results of that poll from Maricopa
County
the final result 51.8 percent in favor
48.2 percent opposed which is the same
ratio of people at Fox who voted that I
should come to work topless
yeah I edged out Trey Gowdy by a couple
of points
on Saturday musk tweeted the people have
spoken Trump will be reinstated vox
populi Vox day I think I that last part
is Latin for Fu you whiny losers
it actually means the voice of the
people is the voice of God whoever heard
that never heard Joy Behar on the toilet
just think about it now it's been a
while since Trump's been on Twitter it's
been so long that Tom Brady is divorced
Kanye is no longer a billionaire and
Elon Omar is now shaving her mustache
three times a week
[Applause]
go clap for that that's disgusting
I disown that
go brother
he was banned on January 8 2021 do you
remember why I sure don't I remember him
saying March peacefully to the Capitol
but earlier in the day Trump didn't seem
too excited to return I bet heard we're
getting a big vote to also go back on
Twitter
but here we're getting a big vote to
also go back on Twitter uh I I don't see
it because I don't see any reason for it
truth social uh is is through the roof
it's doing phenomenally well still must
decision on Trump sets the stage for the
return of the platform's most
influential user since Michael Moore's
fingers got too fat
at least wow
and of course right on cue the media
politicians and celebs already freaking
out from a New York Times op-ed quote I
studied Trump's Twitter use for six
years prepare for the worst
so that's what they do instead of
verifying Hunter's laptop
but anyone who studied Trump's tweets
for six years is to borrow a trump
phrase a loser I mean that person is
living life at a Breakneck Pace I
imagine here she hasn't had sex without
requiring double a batteries in years
then there's Rockstar Jack White
deactivating his record label account
and an absurdly long Instagram post he
compared Trump to the KKK a hate group
that did to blacks with Jack White's
last album to everyone's ears
trust me and I'm a fan
then there was the Panic vomit from the
dopes on cable
anyone who woke up this morning and saw
that news had an avalanche of dread hit
them I'm absolutely disgusted but what
else do we expect from very white
privileged cysts hetero men protecting
each other he's going to politicize it
he's going to use it and all of those
domestic terrorists uh that he's leading
will have a voice should we pray for
Twitter to just collapse it just
underscores the the erratic leadership
of Twitter now under musk but also the
security concerns uh with security
people fleeing Twitter and what that
means for the protection of Americans
private data now that guy's more full of
crap than Jerry nadler's pants
but his reaction was what many echoed
and you're likely to keep hearing that
musk leadership puts data at risk and
it's not just from individuals even
entire networks who you might expect
would welcome more speech no matter who
it's from I mean CBS now cares about
your privacy the network that pioneered
Ambush journalism with 60 minutes late
Friday they shut down their various
accounts and what they called quote in
light of the uncertainty around Twitter
and out of an abundance of caution an
abundance of caution what
I mean that's what the Legacy Media is
known for being overly cautious before
they put something out there to the
public
where should we start you
Russia gate rip gate to find people of
hoax Hunters lapped up as Russian
disinfo when it suits and the networks
jump the gun more often than a sprinter
on meth
but by Sunday morning CBS came back
saying they'll continue to monitor the
situation in response Elon posted this
Brokeback Mountain meme
with the caption our love will never die
he also tweeted this
to CBS they should bring Walter Cronkite
back
as you know Walter Cronkite is dead so
it's not possible but it's funny so the
current funniest dude on Twitter must
has just brought back the previous
reigning Champion Trump and we should
embrace it because it's pissing off
people who would love to ban things they
don't want to hear rather than counter
it with more speech and they're also the
same people who Express more alarm over
tweets than rampant crime soaring
inflation or being on the cusp of a
World War in short they're very selfish
people for they happily accept the
current effed up presidency because it
doesn't affect their fragile psyche and
due to their wealth and high status they
could endure the cost sure everyone's
paying more for food and some people
never make it home from work but at
least these losers you know they don't
wake up at night having to think of
trump
not too bad it's over
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
comedian Jeff Dunham and Walter
she left the White House Press wailing
in distress commenting for two
outnumbered in former White House Press
Secretary Kaylee mcenany
[Applause]
she had a sunny disposition while taking
your deposition outnumbered co-host
Emily compagno
and finally the pilgrims told her no
thanks
Kaylee uh once again you're on my show
with child yes that you are carrying an
unborn baby on your body yes yes at any
moment it could come flying out right at
me right she's gonna be here in seven
days so we've got to come now and
generally
second child the second child usually
comes a week early right that's right I
plan this around that well just so you
know in high school I was uh the center
so
that comes at me I got it
Greg is my OB GYN I am your OBG I'm your
OB G why not
so okay I'm coming to you first because
you know you work with Trump is he going
to return to Twitter so if I had to
guess I would say yes he said no but
look he's got what 90 million followers
and Joe Biden has 36 million so Biggest
Loser hardest hit is Joe Biden I don't
appreciate being called a loser on your
show though what did I do because you
said that anyone who studies Trump's
tweets for six years is a loser I study
them for four that was his press
secretary well you were being paid to
that's different government salary paid
yes that's that's right no I would just
say this I I think he should come back
to Twitter I mean 90 million people he
got in in 24 hours if he's running for
president how can you not use that
platform
um but my favorite is the NAACP
president he said that Elon is failing
democracy and then you go over to Face
the Nation these like Sunday shows which
are you know high-minded right well they
had an expert on who said this is 100
Russian disinformation that fueled the
poll this is the gru speaking not the
people of the world I mean come on buddy
really Russia we're gonna go back to
Russia and failing democracy sounds
familiar that's amazing all right
so please we have now we don't just have
five dummies today we have six right
Walter yeah good to see you normally the
introduces me Greg no one introduced me
at all no one said I was here no one
said it yet I said you were here well I
said Jeff Dunham and Walter okay you're
the only one I am the only one we're
happy to be here I'm happy you're here
because finally I'm taller than somebody
[Laughter]
I want to know where Tyrus is Tyrus is I
think he's coming in later this week or
is he taking Thanksgiving off I don't
know what he's not coming in later this
week yeah we're here all week you like
Tyrus I could kick his ass
I could take him you know if he was here
your head would already be off yeah
and God knows what he'd be doing down
your neck
my data would fit but anyway
talk to you now Jeff okay fine yes don't
you love to see that how they call they
were filled with an avalanche of dread
it's about their psyche they don't they
they don't show any pain for the
inflation or crime but they're worried
they're worried about the Trump coming
back yeah no I think it's gonna be great
Aaron Lyrica wants kofisi that's what we
want yes yes you are like a the average
uh Fox News fan aren't you I am I have
an eight-track
do you play uh what party of the body do
you reply uh you reply the relief Factor
what the hell did you just say I know
did you ever his hand whoever in his
mortgage she's a joke
they're going to ask a question wait for
the joke Greg I'm sorry okay fine and I
thought you were made of wood yeah yeah
another one you should sit on Jeff's
other knee it's hilarious
oh my God I'm arguing with a dummy
yeah
all right Emily are you surprised by the
left's outrage no absolutely not and I
have to focus for a moment on the CBS
what they did
that to me because you know we expect a
lot of Hysteria coming out of of the
libs and the progressive left and the
wokes and everyone but the media writ
large for them to come out in their you
know self-perceived austerity and say we
are closely monitoring the situation
where have you been the past few years
you know democrat-led cities triple
digit spikes in violent crimes crickets
12 police officers shot in one week last
month silence record-breaking migrants
die at the southern border 856 this
fiscal year nothing from them whatsoever
but Donald Trump returning to a social
media app pandemonium yeah I mean you
know what though let the libs burn
themselves out because as far as I'm
concerned I come to Fox news for News
and I go to Twitter for hysteria
well John
this is kind of like an interesting
analogy that Emily brought up cat you
kind of like when the media responds to
uh Trump they have to like they're like
they're like a pet they have to run
around and run around in circles you
just have to wait till they tire out and
then you get on with your day how did
you take the news what did you do
nothing
uh I also don't believe all these people
who hate Trump saying that they're upset
about him being back on Twitter because
all of us I mean okay maybe it's just me
but I don't think so my favorite people
to follow on social media are not the
people I like right it's the people who
are the best most entertaining people to
talk about yes
some of you get it
um you know like certain friends you've
met or family you're like oh you're not
gonna believe what she said send it to
the group chat uh so I think the people
who hate Trump are probably the most
excited because they've actually ever
since Trump's been off Twitter they've
had to work a little harder rather than
a lot of these journalists all they
would do was just quote his everything
he tweeted and go wow yeah and that's
what they would do even when he was on
Truth social which I mean but the thing
is he can't go on Twitter because that
that's why you go to truth social to see
him yeah right he can't but he needs to
I mean if he's running for president you
can't leave 90 million people hanging it
will be funny if he just never did
though yeah it would be fine after all
this he never does a tweet yeah yes
that's one thing I'm not tweeting I'm
not tweeting not at all that's one more
thing but if he doesn't how long will
people talk about it yeah he still
doesn't do it yeah that's amazing make
them want you all right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else